[Music]
Christmas light buzzes in orbit scholars
and I've always not further it's
incredible I mean look at me beautiful
Joyride pocket and a giant dragon in the
middle of it I mean it's ordinary it's
absorbed and after people have put it in
the amount of fans as I'm waiting here
all day and night so you're very lucky
to be fit for me was not having any
facial hair which is quite a signature
look for gold
I didn't have a beard investing is being
rapidly recognized in her laughing some
people to time the worst is probably
being around thirteen of a guy farting
and burping at the time were supposed to
be dwarf they're a great sort of species
of people the Royal they're the family
they hold that those kind of you know
have to be pretty strong to their heart
you know when you get on with this able
to with bicker Jose between themselves
but anyone else an outsider comes in
they all stick together
I kind of like that community sensitive
there's a love story in this movie one
of the dwarfs but the other ones to make
you have antennas that I did not get to
be an orphan enough sorry
totally I wish I can have a box for
battered a lily
don't make you very happy yeah we have
them generally made and I guess I'm too
old jealous they couldn't have her
anyways you know who else is going to
get a kitty pants I mean I can't tell
you what he doesn't assert all you see
as you can see this man is not just a
bargeman you see that is much more to be
bharden as over than meets the eye it's
because he's a loving father that he
turns into a hero it's all intertwined
I'm really really happy I'm really proud
of
it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]